usually when government involves it gets
involved it's they're considering one
side and not the other and they usually
over under legislate you know it's and
they it's either you know government
never gets it right it's over here or
it's over here you're he's gonna piss
off somebody you know
um and and I think like so let's let's
let's just game out the four hour work
week okay so there's there's a movement
for a four-hour work week in California
and if Government legislates it it will
create a bunch of unforeseen problems
for like customer service things or you
know you know where you have to react to
things I mean who knows there's I can
guarantee they haven't thought of every
consideration but what it does say is
that companies need to start asking
themselves should we be considering a
four-hour work week and how does a four
hour work week work for us because
the government won't get it right
but but we may be interested in this
and so I think when these things show up
in legislation what it says in some
people's mind and people are asking the
questions
um and I think it's I think instead of
knee-jerking and just fighting against
these things I think companies need to
you know leadership needs to sit down
and say should we have a four-hour work
week how would that look for us how
would it work for us would it work for
our kind of business what if we can only
give it you know what if it works really
well for some people but not all the
people then how do we make sure
everybody you know it creates a lot of
questions that I think we have to go
through the process of trying to figure
it out and if the answer is you know we
could do something again involve the
people are you are you are you
interested
which then raises a whole new question
which I think is also uh uh something
that's showing up in in distributed
workforces is what does a full-time job
mean
and and you know uh older and when I say
older I mean in age uh leaders are
really struggling to understand that you
know I if you're a full-time employee
and I'm giving you Insurance then you're
not allowed to do anything else
but we've but we but we don't know that
because we know that in the past if you
worked from nine to five you can do
whatever you want your nights and
weekends you can have 15 jobs if you
want as long as you're working nights
and weekends but if it's not nine to
five anymore how does that look
can you have two full-time jobs is that
wrong
and a lot of young people cannot
distinguish they're saying you
you say I can do my work whenever I want
I work from home you have no problems
with my performance what do you care
when I work and where I work so what if
you're giving me Insurance thank you
very much I do good work for you
and I can guarantee you that young
people are having these conversations
and they are not encumbered by sort of
traditional way of work working and they
have much more of a blank sheet of paper
now I'm not saying it's right or wrong
I'm saying that it's best to have these
discussions yourself because if you're
not having the discussion yourself then
then the hammer of legislation will
probably come down and solve a few
problems and create a bunch more
um I believe legislation happens and
should happen when there's Massive
Resistance and there is something that
needs to happen and for whatever reason
companies dig in and refuse to do it I
can give you plenty of examples of great
versions of legislation but I think when
it comes to regulating what a work day
looks like
uh I think companies need to having
start having serious conversations and
start in reimagining it's all in flux
everything is in the air and there is no
certainty right now nobody knows what
the future of work is going to look like
none of us every it's like everything's
being tossed up and everybody's looking
up wondering well we can be a company
that just Waits
where is it going to land or we can be a
company that's actually pioneering and
innovating with the future word could
and should look like and by the way
we're doing it with our people we're not
doing it by dictatorship like this is
what's going to happen but rather we're
working with our people and we're all
figuring out what works and what
actually makes for a really great place
to work where you can actually be really
productive and do really well as a
company as well where we can all take
pride that we are Reinventing what the
future of work looks like together and
I'd rather to happen at a company level
than at a government level